little toss it's fantastic to see you
here at learning from when comic-con
Winterhaven enjoying it today it's been
great so nice to see you again Phil that
we're all friends I it's great as always
I I really enjoy doing these conventions
mainly because you know you end up
seeing people they you've always kind of
wanted to meet yourself okay
Katee Sackhoff just touch me I still
haven't quite got over that and and yem
it's been really great and I always
enjoy it but I really find it exhausting
because I put so much energy into kind
of hanging out with people I was saying
that I spent two days being really
social speaking to everyone and no one
gets excluded and then I spent their
next five days
not seeing a soul because it's black my
antidote to doing conventions of so you
can I ask you about Game of Thrones we
saw your kind of Protege is stark last
season in some very interesting moments
didn't we I mean what did you think when
she was with the Hound towards the end
and how she left him so it's a fantastic
performance that may I mean Maisie just
continues to get better and better and
better and the look do you know what I
really love about what she's doing and
this of course is to do with everyone
involved in creating this story
is that it's very easy to use a
character like aria to root for her
because there's so few people that you
can genuinely side with as an audience
member because you know George Martin
continually keeps undermining what we
think we know about characters and so so
it's really it would be easy like in a
normal TV show of this caliber it will
be very not easy just to go identify
with the girl identify with the girl
let's follow through her revenge thing
and and of course what makes Game of
Thrones so unique is that it kind of
does that but it keeps making you go no
there's something not wrong
and it's something not right with Arya
Stark there's something that is broken
inside of her because of her experiences
and so it kind of leaves you with a
little bit of a bad taste in your mouth
and you genuinely go but it's the Hound
don't leave the Hound of course you
understand it and you it makes complete
sense so it's it's a very bittersweet
place there that she is in and and it
will only get more interesting and
complicated I mean obviously last time I
saw Serio we were left with something
that fans are kind of questioning will
we see him again has he actually died
it's at the end for him and I suppose in
a way we had something similar with the
Hound although obviously was left
wounded we didn't actually see him leave
this earth did we so I wondered what
your thoughts on whether the Hound is
now gone for good or do you think we'll
see him back again I think isn't isn't
the beauty of having a story like this
is that it creates its own mythology and
whether you've read the books or not it
doesn't change the outcome because
things will always change
and stories can be told in a million
different ways and when the books are
not finished yet anything can happen so
so it doesn't matter really what will
happen what happens is we start to to
almost like own it ourselves as audience
members we own it and we that's why we
make mythologies about it that's why we
have conspiracy theories about
characters that's why we have these
these forums where people have to talk
about it because it's it's although if
you couldn't talk about it it would be
to someone's like it's all only it's
aware of grieving for people that you
genuinely care about and it's a strange
phenomenon I mean I don't you know most
of the time we just used to going okay
this is a TV show this is a story and
it's kind of straightforward and yet
this is not straightforward at all and
that's why I think it's captured
people's imaginations and not just
people who enjoy watching TV shows not
people just enjoy reading fantasy books
but it's like a cultural phenomena it's
like when you start getting name-checked
by other cultural phenomenons you
realize that something pretty major is
going on which is bigger than a TV show
bigger than a book it's it's it's like
you know suddenly it's suddenly it's
important that politicians name check it
because suddenly become really cool if
you'd name check that you you really
into Game of Thrones which you know it's
just the world we live in
do you think we'll see Syria again I
mean like talking about this kind of
speculation we all have all the time I
don't know how to answer this question
any more because I've answered it so
many times but and I think we've kind of
touched on it before and I last
interview but
it doesn't really matter to me because I
have it I guess be controversial now I
have a theory that that Syrio Forel has
a twin brother but I'm sure Arya Stark
well I did you know what I'm doing right
now I'm planting seeds in George Martin
just putting it out there in the cosmos
just planting seeds and it doesn't even
matter we never see this interview it
will just be in in the ether and here we
just wake up one morning a goat
if Syrio Forel had a brother called
Morelle Pharrell that's ridiculous
oh I've just inked it now it'll never
happen wouldn't that be fabulous over
it'd be ridiculous
I would have to pay someone a lot of
money there's actually been rumors
recently that's Tom Letitia who played
Jack and Hegar might be coming back to
the show me what do you think about that
I think it makes perfect sense because
if he as we know he is that he is a
faceless man so it makes perfect sense I
know it doesn't happen in the books but
it makes perfect sense for a TV audience
to to for him something to go hello it's
me again it makes perfect sense also
because of of where Aria needs to go
next so yeah of course it makes perfect
sense and it makes perfect sense because
he is the one who gave her the coin and
the last thing we saw was that that
bargain that deal was being made so he
cause he does and he's brilliant so I am
NOT bitter in any way about him if he's
back in the show he might be very quick
grisly we don't know who it
that would make me feel better talking
about grisly ends how did he feel when
he saw on the screen how they brought to
life that fight between the viper and
the mountain is quite recent woman I
couldn't watch it a second time I
watched it live with a bunch of people
in Texas I think it was like a game of
Thrones and I was like the guest and it
was amazing it was truly amazing
and it was you know Oberyn I mean is
such an amazing character so beautifully
played so touched with his loyalty to
Tyrion I mean it completely blew me away
so so of course a new is coming but I
had no idea was going to be so explicit
as now I'd really love his people to
question whether he might be dead or not
because I bet you there are some people
that think there's some kind of
conspiracy that people can come up with
that might suggest that Oberyn Martell
is not actually dead but that that what
you saw was Jack was just a flesh wound
re inflate you that head well who knows
you know you can bring him back from the
dead obviously we've got a massive
brilliant casting Game of Thrones I
wondered if you could bring anyone in to
show whether they were film or TV actor
who would you love to see in Game of
Thrones and why Gary Oldman
just because I think he's that my
favorite is my favorite that could be
really interesting I think I think if
Jessica Lange is not doing another
season of American Horror Story I think
she would be brilliant to get in yeah
get some heavy heavy ways because I mean
well the thing is now with Game of
Thrones any actor who reliefs up their
hand and goes can I be a part of that
that's what I guess is happening right
now when we did it it was still you know
what one season to the other we they
what people were wondering whether it
was going to be recommissioned it was
still tenure you know it's still fragile
now I can't imagine them only because
the viewing figures increase every year
so so it will it will end it will it
will end whether it ends I have this
theory that what will happen George will
keep writing the books the Caesar the
series will end and then George will be
in a bit of a problem because he'll be
like oh the TV show has ended do I do I
now carry on writing that story or do I
do something really subversive and do
some an alternative ending it could
change publishing history publishing the
publishing world forever
because when is that ever happened
before where you had a TV show that
catches up and surpasses a book series
and then what does the author do I think
we will come to that point and not for
because you know George has to take as
long as he he needs to take with his
books you know I'm not one of those
people other thing it's just it takes as
long as it takes but I think for that
reason I mean I think the show will end
before the books do and then it'll be
interesting and then and then the TV
show will end with certain characters
alive and then George will look at it
and go no I will kill them all and other
people will be alive and then that'd be
really radical yeah maybe I've over
thought it's too much I love I love this
deep thought giving it though I do love
it my talk is because whenever I do
conventions we always talk about it we
talk about it amongst ourselves it's a
strange thing to be an actor working on
a job and yet we all have been turned
into nerds about every single one of us
I don't know a single member of the cast
who isn't a nerd about
it's almost impossible not to become one
got to ask you quickly about how much
you're enjoying being part of that
enormous crazy film world even a nought
part of an enormous crazy TV world of
Star Wars I can't talk about Star Wars
but it's as a Star Wars fan it's a dream
come true so it's it's a it's kind of
strange when you do something that feels
very familiar and also makes you just
want to put your head in a bag and
scream which is kind of all I really can
do so yeah it's it's it's it's a it's a
beautiful wonderful thing and and I'm so
pleased that JJ Abrams is is doing it
because I think I have so much respect
for that man he has so much enthusiasm
and he it's in very safe hands I'm sure
I know given how brilliant you are as a
swordsman and how brilliant Syria was as
well that everyone will be dying for you
to wield a lightsaber how much would you
like to wield a lightsaber and how
likely are we to do that happen I'd love
to wield a lightsaber but I I'm having I
don't know if it's just the mood I'm in
this weekend but I so want to be a sick
no more mr. nice guy well first as
always it's been absolutely a pleasure
talking to you thanks so much your time
thank you so much always a pleasure
you